สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะครูเรียม
สวัสดีสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูเรียนวันนี้วันอะไร
คะวันนี้วันจันทร์ค่ะ
ค่ะ
วันจันทร์ที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันจันทร์ที่ 3
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนกรกฎาคมค่ะ
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
ปีค.ศอะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ 2023 ค่ะ
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะ
ตอนนี้
9 โมงค่ะ
10 นาทีค่ะ
ใช่ค่ะก็เลยไม่ได้ 9 นาทีเลยนักเรียนก็จะ
แบบว่า
ทำไมต้อง 9 โมง 9 นาทีก็คนไทยนะคะชอบเลข 9
ไง
ใช่ค่ะผู้หญิงหรือว่าเราจะเจอกันพรุ่งนี้
9 โมง 9 นาทีได้ไหม
ไม่เป็นไรค่ะไม่เป็นไรเจอกันวันนี้แหละ
ค่ะโอเคแล้วไม่ต้อง 9 โมง 9 นาทีก็ได้ค่ะ
เราแค่อัดวีดีโอเราไม่ได้จะทำอะไรผู้หญิง
ไม่ได้จะคลอดลูกผู้หญิงไม่ได้ไม่ได้จะ
แต่งงานที่ต้องดูเวลา
ผู้หญิงแต่งงานน่ะแต่งงานดูเวลาได้แต่
คลอดลูกนี้ต้องดูเวลาด้วยหรอคะ
เขาก็ดูเวลางานไง
หรือว่าแบบปวดท้อง
อย่าเพิ่งยังไม่ 9:00 น
อีกผู้หญิงคิดว่าถ้าท้องแล้วแบบโอ้เจ็บ
ท้องมากๆก็จะบอกคุณหมอว่าออกเลยค่ะออกเลย
ค่ะ
คุณหมอบอกว่ารอก่อนรอก่อนเนี่ย
รอ 9 โมง 9 นาที
ไม่ๆๆค่ะไม่เอาแล้วค่ะ
เพราะมีลูก 1 คนเนี่ย
แพงมากๆนะคะครูเรียมไม่ใช่มีลูก 1 คนต้อง
จ่ายค่าอาหาร
จ่ายค่าเสื้อผ้า
จ่ายค่าไปโรงเรียน
คิดว่าที่เขาบอกว่าถ้าเราแต่งงานแล้วก็มี
ลูกแล้วมันแพงมากๆน่าจะเป็นค่าเรียนนะคะ
เวลาเด็กๆไปโรงเรียนว่าเราก็ไปโรงเรียน
ตั้งแต่อายุเท่าไหร่อ่ะ 3 ขวบนะคะ 3 ขวบ 4
ขวบไปโรงเรียนนะคะ
ใช่แล้วแบบไปโรงเรียนถ้าไปโรงเรียนดีๆมัน
ก็จะแพง
จ่ายแบบเป็นล้านก็มีนะ
ใช่ค่ะแล้วตั้งแต่ 3 ขวบใช่ไหมคะกว่าเรา
จะเรียนเนี่ยเรียนจนจบอายุก็น่าจะเรียน
เราเรียนจบอายุประมาณ 22 เนาะอายุ 22 อ่ะ
อายุประมาณ
ใช่ประมาณ 18  19 ปีเลยนะคะที่คุณพ่อคุณ
แม่ต้องมีเงินจ่ายค่าโรงเรียนให้เราเรียน
น่ะ
ใช่ค่ะถ้าเกิดอายุประมาณ 3-4 ขวบ
เอาเด็กๆหรือว่าเอาลูกไปเรียนอนุบาลก็จะ
มีโรงเรียนแบบนานาชาติที่ให้พูด 2 ภาษา
ภาษาอังกฤษภาษาไทยหรือว่าภาษาไทยภาษาจีน
หรือบางทีไม่มีภาษาไทยก็มีนะใช่แบบภาษา
อังกฤษ
เก่งๆก็ต้องแพงอีกค่ะแล้วกว่าลูกจะเรียน
จบถ้าลูกเรียนจบแล้วคิดว่าคุณพ่อคุณแม่
แบบเฮ้อ
สบายใจ
คุณพ่อคุณแม่จะ 5 เหรอคะคุณพ่อคุณแม่ต้อง
ดีใจสิลูกหญิงแบบเย้ดีใจลูกเรียน
ดีใจก็คือลูกก็เป็นเป็นคนที่เก่งเรียนจบ
เรียมดู YouTube วันก่อนๆเมื่อประมาณ 3
วันที่แล้วเรียมเห็นว่ามียูทูปเบอร์คนนึง
เขามีลูกแล้วเขาก็ส่งลูกไปเรียนโรงเรียน
นานาชาติค่ะ
เรียนอนุบาลเรียนอนุบาลอายุประมาณ
6 ขวบ
6 ขวบเรียนอนุบาลจบแล้วเราก็จะเปลี่ยน
เป็นขึ้นชั้นประถมใช่ไหมคะ
เขาก็มีงานรับใบประกาศ
เขาก็รอให้นะเขาก็ร้องไห้
ที่ลูกเรียนจบอนุบาล
ทางครูหญิงเรียนหนังสือ
เดี๋ยวเวลาที่เราต้องใส่ไอ้หมวกแบบนี้
หรือว่าใส่ชุดที่เด็กเขาใส่อ่ะชุดเรียนจบ
อ่ะมันไม่ใช่เรียนจบอนุบาลนะเราต้องเรียน
จบตอนเราอายุ 22 ปีนะคะใช่ค่ะครูหญิงตอน
ที่เรียนได้ใส่ชุดแบบนี้เรียมก็เรียนจบ
ตอนอายุประมาณ 22 ปีเหมือนกัน
แต่ตอนนี้อายุ 6 ขวบก็เรียนจบได้แล้ว
แล้วก็มีใส่ชุดครุยเนอะชุดครุย
แล้วก็มีหมวก
แล้วก็รับใบเหมือนๆเราเรียนจบตอนอายุ 22
เลยนะคะใช่ค่ะครูหญิงตอนนี้เป็นแบบนี้ 6
ขวบก็รับปริญญา
แล้วก็เรียนประถมไปอีก 6 ปีใช่ไหมคะอายุ
12 ปีก็มี
รับใบประกาศแบบนี้อีก 1 ครั้ง
แล้วก็
เรียนชั้นมัธยมต้นอีก 3 ปีอายุ 15 อายุ 15
ก็มีรับแบบนี้อีก 1 ครั้งอายุ 15 เนี่ย
รับไป 3 ครั้งแล้ว
รับตอน 6 ขวบรับตอนอายุ 12 แล้วก็รับตอน
อายุ 15 แล้วเรียนจบมปลายตอนอายุ 18
เนี่ยต้องใส่ชุดครุยรับแบบนี้อีก 1 ครั้ง
ไหมคะ
ต้องรับไหมหรอใส่ๆ
อันนี้เหมือนเหมือนฝรั่งไหมแบบผู้หญิงเคย
ดูแบบซีรีส์หรือว่าหนังฮอลลีวูดเนี่ยเวลา
เด็กใช่ไหมอายุ 18 นะคะอายุ 18 เนี่ย
เรียนจบมปลายเขาก็จะใส่ชุดใส่ชุดครุยแบบ
นี้นะแล้วก็รับมีกระดาษม้วนๆแบบนี้แหละ
เป็นกระดาษนะคะ
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยใส่ชุดครุยใส่หมวกแล้วก็รับ
เนี่ย
1 ครั้งเท่านั้นตอนอายุ 20
เรียมก็เหมือนกันเตรียมก็ใส่ชุดครุยใส่
หมวกแล้วก็รับใบประกาศหรือว่าถ้าเกิดอายุ
22 เขาก็จะพูดว่ารับปริญญา
รับปริญญามาแล้วก็เป็นครั้งเดียวที่ใส่
ชุดครุย
แต่ตอนนี้ตอนนี้เห็นแบบเด็กๆ 6 ขวบ 12
ขวบใส่ชุดแบบนี้เรียมก็เลยแบบ
นี้หรอดีไหม
คุณพ่อคุณแม่ก็ต้องจ่ายเงินเพิ่มไหมคะ
เพราะว่าตอนครูเรียมแล้วก็ครูหญิงเนี่ย
เรียนจบตอนอายุ 22 อ่ะแล้วเรารับปริญญา
ใช่ไหมใส่ชุดครุยเนี่ยชุดครุยเนี่ยนะคะ
เราต้องจ่ายเงินนะ
ตอนที่เรียนรับปริญญา
รินก็ซื้อนะซื้อชุดครุยแล้วตอนนี้ก็เก็บ
ไว้ในตู้เสื้อผ้าที่บ้านก็คิดตอนนั้นจะ
ซื้อมาทำไม
ผู้หญิงถามได้ไหมคะว่าครูเรียมซื้อชุด
ครุยอ่ะเท่าไหร่อ่ะคะ
หนูจำไม่ได้แต่เป็นหลักพันนะผู้หญิง
ราคาแบบ
เป็นหลักพันบาทอ่ะ
ค่ะแต่ว่าจำไม่ได้คือนานแล้วมากกว่า 10
ปี
ไปคิดดูว่าครูหญิงเนี่ย
แต่ว่าอะไร
ไม่ได้ซื้อคือยังไม่ได้ซื้อ
เช่านะคะเช่าก็คือเราจ่ายเงินเขาแล้วก็จะ
มีชุดครุยมาคิดว่าเขาให้เช่าประมาณ 1
เดือนมั้ง
1 เดือน
ใช่ค่ะพอครบ 1 เดือนคุณหญิงก็เอาชุดเนี่ย
ไปคืนที่ร้านนะคะแต่จำไม่ได้เหมือนกันว่า
ค่าเช่าเท่าไหร่แต่ผู้หญิงคิดว่ามันนานนะ
เพราะว่าจำได้ว่าผู้หญิงเอาชุดครุยเนี่ย
ใส่แล้วก็กลับบ้านไปถ่ายรูปกับคุณพ่อคุณ
แม่คุณตาคุณยายถ่ายรูปกับคนในครอบครัวที่
ไม่ได้ไม่ได้มางานครูหญิงนะคะ
จำได้แล้วว่าทำไมเรียมถึงซื้อชุดครุย
เพราะว่าเตรียมเรียนที่ปทุมธานีใกล้ๆกับ
กรุงเทพฯ
แล้วเรียมต้องเอาชุดครุยกลับมาที่บ้านมา
ถ่ายรูปกับครอบครัว
แล้วก็แบบถ่ายรูปถ่ายรูปกับหลายๆคนก็เลย
แบบซื้อซื้อชุดครุยไม่ต้องไม่ต้องเช่า
เพราะว่าถ้าเกิดเช่าแล้วก็ต้องเอาไปคืน
ก็เลยคิดซื้อเลยดีกว่าใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะ
เด็กๆ 3 ขวบรับปริญญาแล้วคิดว่า
นักเรียนนักเรียนในนี้นะนักเรียนในช่อง
comprehible ไทยอาจจะไม่เคยเห็นมาก่อนนะ
ที่ประเทศไทยรับปริญญาตอนอายุ 22 เป็นยัง
ไง
เพราะมันเป็นยังไงอ่ะคะเพราะว่าผู้หญิง
เนี่ยทั้งผู้หญิงรับปริญญามันไม่ได้
เหมือนกับที่อื่นที่อื่นขนาดนั้น
[เพลง]
ตอนที่เตรียมรับปริญญานะคะต้องแต่งตัวแบบ
เรียบร้อยมากๆ
ต้องแต่งตัวนี้มากๆ
ต้องมีชุดนักศึกษา
ข้างใน
แล้วก็มีชุดครุย
ข้างในเนี่ยครูหญิงใส่เสื้อยืดแล้วก็ใส่
กางเกงได้ไหมแล้วก็ใส่ชุดครุยก็ชุดครุยก็
ปิดแล้วไม่ได้
ไม่ได้หรอคะก็ต้องใส่ชุดนักเรียนชุดนัก
ศึกษานะเสื้อสีขาว
แล้วก็ถ้าเป็นผู้หญิงเหมือนในรูปใช่ไหมคะ
ก็ใส่กระโปรงสีดำแล้วก็มีชุดครุยมีนัก
เรียนเห็นข้างนอกเนี่ยที่เขาใส่อยู่เนี่ย
คือชุดครุยใช่ค่ะแล้วอากาศประเทศไทยร้อน
มากนะ
แล้วก็ใส่ประมาณ 2 ชั้นใส่เสื้อผ้า 2
ชั้นชุดนักศึกษาแล้วก็ชุดครุย
แล้วผมล่ะคะ
ปล่อยผมได้หรอผมเปิดให้เห็นหน้า
ผู้หญิงนะคะ
เปิดให้เห็นหน้าแล้วก็ห้ามทำผมแบบแฟนซี
ไม่ได้ทำไม่ได้
ถ้าตอนครูหญิงนะคะตอนครูหญิงสมมุติคุย
หญิงเรียนอย่างนี้ผู้หญิงเปลี่ยนสีผมไม่
ว่าจะเป็นสีน้ำตาลสีบลอนด์นั้นนักเรียน
ไม่ใช่สีเขียวสีเหลืองอ่ะหรือว่าเป็นสี
น้ำตาลเนี่ยถ้าคุณหญิงเรียนจบแล้วจะรับ
ปริญญาแบบในรูปเนี่ยผมผู้หญิงเนี่ยนะคะ
จากสีน้ำตาลสีบรอนซ์สีอะไรก็ตามนะคะต้อง
เปลี่ยนกลับมาเป็นสีดำใช่ค่ะตอนคุย
บางคนก็เอาสเปรย์นะสเปรย์สีดำฉีด
หลังจากนั้นเราจะรู้สึก
ปกติเราก็รับแค่ 1 วันเนาะ 1 วัน
ใช่ค่ะแล้วก็ต่างหูแบบนี้ต่างหูสร้อยแหวน
นาฬิกา
ใส่เข้าไปรับปริญญาไม่ได้
อ๋อต้องถอดต่างหูขอสร้อยถอดทุกอย่างเลย
ติดกิ๊บได้ไหมคะติดกิ๊บสีดำ
แบบนี้เนาะได้ใช่ไหมคะ
แต่คิดว่าต้องเป็นกิ๊บแบบเล็กๆที่มองไม่
ค่อยเห็น
เนาะแต่นักเรียนจะมองไม่เห็นนะคะเพราะมัน
เป็นวีดีโอ
ใช่ค่ะ
ผู้ชายก็ต้องแต่งแบบ 2 ชั้นเหมือนกัน
ผู้ชายก็ใส่เป็นกางเกงขายาว
แล้วก็เสื้อเชิ้ต
ค่ะ
แล้วที่สำคัญนะที่มหาลัยของเรียนก็จะมี
แบบ
รุ่นน้อง
รุ่นน้องที่แบบ
นี่เขาทำอะไรคะ
เหมือนรุ่นน้องคนที่กำลังเรียนอยู่เรียน
ยังไม่จบเนี่ยจะเป็นรุ่นน้องก็จะแบบมา
แสดงความยินดีแบบดีใจด้วยนะคะพี่ที่เรียน
จบเรียนจบไปแล้วก็จะกอดกอดคอกัน
กอดกัน
แล้วก็ร้องเพลง
แล้วก็แบบมีก้ม
ก้มแบบนี้เหมือนคล้ายๆเชียร์ไว้
หรอคะพอร้องเพลงร้องเพลงจบจากก้มเงยหน้า
เย้ใช่ๆเหมือนแบบ congrated
Congratulation  congrated
สนุกไหมคะว่าครูหญิงไม่มีสนุกมากค่ะผู้
หญิงแล้วเราก็แบบรู้สึกรู้สึกดีใจที่น้อง
ๆอายุน้อยกว่ามาแบบแสดงความยินดีเขาก็มา
บูมให้แบบนี้ร้องเพลงเต้นให้
แล้วก็น้องๆแล้วก็ครอบครัวของเราก็จะเอา
ตุ๊กตามาให้เอาช่อดอกไม้
เอาช่อดอกไม้แบบนี้มาให้
ตุ๊กตา
ที่หมีที่ใส่ชุดครุย
จากมหาวิทยาลัยที่เราเรียนนะ
มันเป็นครั้งเดียว
ครั้งเดียวในชีวิตถ้าไม่เรียนไม่เรียนแบบ
สูงขึ้นนะ
ใช่ค่ะก็ได้เหมือนกันแล้วก็ไม่ต้องไม่
ต้องใส่ชุดครุยด้วยก็ได้มั้งไม่ต้องซื้อ
ชุดครุยไม่ต้องเช่าชุดครุย
ใช่เพราะว่าแบบบางคนอาจจะคิดว่าถ้าเรารัก
มันแพงอย่างนี้บางคนก็มาอยู่กรุงเทพฯแต่
ที่บ้านไม่ได้อยู่กรุงเทพฯเพราะกลับบ้าน
แล้วอย่างนี้ค่ะมาเรียนที่กรุงเทพฯใช่ไหม
ก็ไม่รับก็ได้แต่ถ้าผู้หญิงเรียน
มหาวิทยาลัยแบบครูเรียมที่ต้องสอบใช่ไหม
เวลาอายุ 18 ต้องสอบแล้วก็สอบสอบแข่งๆๆ
แล้วก็เข้าได้ผู้หญิงก็รับค่ะ
ก็มาที่กรุงเทพฯ
เรียนจบแล้ว
ญาติพี่น้องทั้งหมดนะส่วนใหญ่จะมาตอนรับ
ปริญญาตอนอายุ 22 นี่แหละถ้าเกิดเรียนต่อ
สูงขึ้นก็อาจจะมีคนมางานรับปริญญาเราน้อย
ลงน้อยค่ะน้อยแต่ถ้าเราเรียนอันนี้ 4 ปี
เรียนจบเท่านี้นะ
คุณพ่อคุณแม่ญาติพี่น้องคุณปู่คุณย่าคุณ
ลุงคุณป้าแล้วก็เพื่อนใช่ไหมทุกคนก็มา
แล้วก็บอกดีใจด้วยนะคะเรียนดีใจด้วยนะ
เรียมใหญ่แต่พอรับเสร็จแล้วก็คิด
เหนื่อย
เหนื่อยมาก
[เพลง]
แต่ก็แค่วันเดียวนะ
ก็โอเคนะคะ 1 วัน 1 ครั้งพอแล้ว
แล้วก็ไปทำงาน
ใช่หรือถ้าไม่เรียนแล้วแต่ถ้าเรียนสูง
ขึ้นก็รับนะเออมันก็ดูเป็นความแบบเรา
เรียนจบแล้วใช่ไหมคะก็ไม่รู้เหมือนกันว่า
ประเทศนักเรียนเนี่ย
รับปริญญาเนี่ยเหมือนที่ไทยแบบที่ครู
เรียมเล่าให้ฟังไหมหรือว่าเด็กๆอ่ะอายุ 6
ขวบมีใส่ชุดครุยรับมีเหมือนกันไหมใช่ไหม
ก็ comment คุยกับเราได้นะคะใช่ค่ะแล้ว
ริมก็อยากรู้ว่าถ้าเกิดใครที่เคยมางานรับ
ปริญญาในประเทศไทย
สนุกไหม
บอกได้นะคะ
ใช่ค่ะแต่ว่าวันนี้เวลาหมดแล้วค่ะผู้หญิง
ใช่ค่ะแล้วเดี๋ยวเรามาเจอกันใหม่วีดีโอ
หน้านะคะใช่ค่ะต้องลาไปก่อนสวัสดีค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะ
[เพลง]